problemi tecnici
Buonasera a tutti
Once Upon a Time
C'era una volta
e poi è arrivato l'intelligenza
artificiale io stasera vi racconterò una
storia una favola
è la mia favola della mia vita
ed è piena di passione
sono occasioni diverse che si
intrecciano molto spesso una con l'altra
la più grande passione che ho avuto e
che ho vissuto e che vivo tutore e
quella della moda
però c'è anche quella dell'arte e della
cultura il teatro
e fare del bene alle persone gli altri e
lavorare molto con i ragazzi mi piace
moltissimo
testa modella Fashion
Designer stilista
è stato un
un viaggio
che ho voluto fare io perché non mi ci
trovavo più come modella
e questo è stato dopo
5-6 anni che i miei genitori a tre
Quando avevo 13 anni mi hanno mandato
nelle scuole in estero in Inghilterra in
Francia in Svizzera francese in e poi in
Italia
in Italia
ho subito
fatto dai Daily Caroselli non so se
qualcuno di voi si ricorda i Caroselli i
ragazzi forse no
nessuno
Sì vabbè
e uno diventava una giovane
tedesca Perché io sono di nazionalità
tedesca una giovane tedesca arrivata in
Italia che fa subito i suoi primi
Caroselli con Dorelli con Jannacci ha
avuto una visibilità Incredibile è stato
molto emozionante
sono stata anche
ho vinto un premio a Cannes per delle
Caroselli per un Carosello
e sono sono diventata Lady di universi
ed è tutto molto bello però sapevo che
non era proprio quello che volevo fare
io volevo di più volevo essere io quella
che faceva le cose
belle che rimanevano
E allora e nel giro di pochi mesi sono
diventata stilista
Prima sono stata qualche un po' di tempo
da amici e non nei presciano in un
maglificio dove ho cercato di rubare di
captare tutti i segreti possibili
e c'era la mamma di questi miei amici
che non mi diceva niente mi raccontava
niente io dovevo veramente stare lì e
cercare di capire da me è stato
una sfida incredibile molto bella anche
se ero un po' arrabbiata ma
la signora non si faceva
commuovere E io invece
sono stata lì a captare e ho imparato
poi
allora ho capito che era la mia passione
la moda
E allora sono cominciato le notti
in bianco a disegnare a colorare a fare
mettere insieme
testuti belli
colori diversi
O
ho lavorato moltissimo sempre con
grandissima voglia di fare voglia di
arrivare
e la prima volta che ho avuto una
piccola collezione e l'ho presentata o
subito ho trovato diversi clienti
e questo è stato meraviglioso è stata
una cosa fantastica
e la passione
quella più grande la mia
dopo un po' di tempo
amici miei mi avevano proposto di fare
di entrare nel gruppo giovane di un
di un partito politico non vi dico quale
non voglio pubblicizzare pubblicità
politica ma è stata una bellissima
esperienza perché
c'erano ancora i comizi in piazza e
c'era tanta di quella gente migliaia di
gente che cercava di capire e di
comprendere di
sapere cosa voleva fare questa
importante già importante stilista
per l'Italia nell'Europa perché volevo
un'Italia più moderna io che parlo
cinque lingue che ho vissuto in tanti
paesi che conosco direi tutta l'Europa
mi è piaciuto tantissimo
e È stata una esperienza bella Appunto
che non aveva niente a che fare con il
mio lavoro però era molto molto
divertente molto emozionante
[Musica]
Naturalmente
sono stata dopo anni
e ho ricevuto un premio molto molto
bello sono diventata come datore della
Repubblica
e credo anche per tutto il tempo tutto
la
passione che ho avuto che ho fatto
vedere che ho fatto vivere
a molti ragazzi anche
e
Penso che
sia il premio più bello che ho avuto
perché ne ho avuto tanti
comunque
dopo nel 2000 mi affaccio al teatro
teatro o e opera e disegno
i costumi delle opere
anche quello è una grandissima
emozione perché bisogna lavorare insieme
con il regista con il coreografo bisogna
fare un insieme di cose bellissime per
la gente che si porti a casa delle cose
indimenticabili E quante volte ho visto
piangere
di più di 2000
spettatori del grande teatro di
Torre del Lago dopo una mia Butterfly
che piangevano a dirotto E dicevano
Quanto era bello
è una emozione incredibile che faceva
che fa comunque parte della passione
perché senza passione non l'avrei potuto
fare la passione viene prima e poi ci
sono le emozioni
dopo
cioè dopo Naturalmente tutto insieme la
moda continua
il teatro continua
è arrivato il
Oppure facciamo prima la solitarietà
perché sono le cose un po' miste
i covet
sono riuscita
veramente
terribilmente mossa questa cosa e ho
fatto
ho prodotto e disegnato
uno scialle molto bello In una carezza
sulla pelle una cosa bellissima i colori
importanti primaverili
per il
per infermiere
le infermiere che sono state almeno due
o tre settimane
di fila in prima linea negli ospedali
è stato anche quello è una cosa
fantastica
e naturalmente
[Applauso]
e sempre nella
[Musica]
in questa passione di solidarietà
sociale diciamo ho fatto diverse
programmi Questo è per ricordarvi che
sono io
la mia coperta di Linus
per ricordarvi per ricordare che
ci sono
che ho fatto diverse cose molte cose di
beneficenza
molto spesso per le donne
che avevano problemi con
il seno
e
Ladies del dragonboat che è una cosa
molto divertente sul tuo di solito sul
lago ma potrebbe benissimo essere qui
sulla Laguna
Ne potremmo parlare
e
poi vabbè dal teatro
torniamo un attimo indietro ho fatto
molte cose con i ragazzi con i ragazzi
giovani
[Musica]
perché è importante perché devono
sognare devono sognare
e devono fare i loro le loro scelte
poi
dopo Naturalmente il mio sguardo al
futuro perché finora vi ho raccontato
quello che c'era il futuro il futuro
è sicuramente
l'intelligenza artificiale in qualche
modo anche se ancora è un po' nebuloso
un po'
confuso per me
però c'è
e ho fatto durante il
lockdown il mio primo NFC che è una
carta da gioco
con i cuori della passione
e dobbiamo andare avanti Cioè In effetti
intelligenza artificiale ci piace non ci
piace farà male non farà male
diventeranno passioni
chissà Penso di sì E siccome sono
curiosa e mi piacciono le cose nuove
voglio e voglio esserci
comunque
[Musica]
la creatività diceva qualcuno
è contagiosa era Einstein la creatività
è contagiosa andate a trasmetterla
non come con il covet solo la creatività
la creatività che dà tanto
e poi per finire vi dico che
cercate la vostra passione se non lo
avete ancora trovata cercatela perché
c'è
e la Se cercate la trovate la passione è
fondamentale e la vita è importante
e con la passione
si fa Tutto naturalmente può far male
può far bene
però si impara da tutto
Grazie
[Applauso]